[Music]
it really is kind of a trip because sex
is like so iconic
it feels surreal when you think about
fashion and shopping the world collides
at facts and so you always know about
the windows you always know how
monumental they are and to be like
literally a model in the window is
everything
this is insane as a little queer boy
that grew up in a tiny town in north
wales watching films like home alone and
spider-man beat in new york city i'm
getting to have my own window at saks
fifth avenue is absolutely insane it's
kind of a full circle moment
i actually
am from birmingham alabama and used to
work for a saks fifth avenue
there for trish mcavoy years and years
and years later i'm in
the saxophone avenue window how crazy is
that
[Music]
you have to step it up when it's an all
winter season
this is such an incredibly strong pool
of talent so i knew coming into this
competition right off the bat that i had
to bring my best and my brightest it
feels surreal because you know it was
about a decade since the last time i did
this
and i didn't want to say we were doing
it on a smaller scale but we were doing
it on a smaller scale
it was a once in a lifetime opportunity
it's something that i we've all probably
fantasized about as people who are
shoppers and uh and you know and lovers
of great windows and i really feel
awesome i feel privileged i feel lucky
my fashion and drag has definitely
evolved i've definitely become a mature
and i've been very
very particular about the things that i
want to be seen and things that i don't
want to be photographed and things that
i want to wear especially on the
mainstays of the drag race so it's
definitely been gotten more mature but
still
i got cooler honestly let's be honest
i've gotten cooler
[Music]
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos